There are several ways to look
at different intrusion detection
approaches.
>From the point of view of
how data is analyzed, or
how intrusion is detected,
we have two approaches.
One is misuse detection,
also known as signature-based detection.
The other one is anomaly detection.
Misuse detection models all
represents long intrusions.
Anomaly detection models all
represents normal activities.
>From the point of view
of deployment strategy,
we can deploy an IDS on end host,
or a network perimeter.
In terms of how the detection
models are viewed and
maintained, we can use manual
encoding of expert knowledge.
All hand written rules, or
we can apply machine running
algorithms to data to automatically
learn the detection rules.